hi there welcome to Westeros weekly this
is the Q&A show where we take your
questions and dissection divulge talk
about conspiracy conclusions and
questions that you have and is a big
question this week we're going to go to
insects but first up my name is tole
Molina this is Monte Rea yay
I knew your name yeah but the big big
big question this week we're gonna get
right to it
yeah is someone sabotaging Daenerys
Targaryen she keeps failing yeah [ __ ]
out of luck man she was so confident and
of course her overconfidence was her
weakness I was the deal you've got a
couple of ideas is it I do okay so
here's that we kind of went into it a
little bit last week but this concept of
someone on the inside working against
Daenerys is starting to make more and
more sense got a mole or a rat
potentially a molar and you got mad at
me last time when I jokingly said it
could be Masson day yeah I'm not happy
about this yeah but it totally could be
because of one particular scene I
noticed this time when Jon Snow and his
boy Davos landed at Dragonstone they had
a very cordial conversation with Musante
and it was a little bit like awkward
smoking it went it felt like his awkward
small talk and I even was like BAM asan
day like he ain't cute like very warm
but you know you can be nice right but
watching it again there's a couple of
clues that I got into okay first of all
he says oh I don't recognize your accent
where are you from
so let's remember one thing about mr.
Davos Seaworth
yeah where's he been everywhere
everywhere you can go so him not
recognizing our accent not being of a
place that means okay you're from so
there's something unusual about this
there are a lot of places and usually
it's hard from the last couple episodes
it takes a while to get somewhere by a
ship okay so not everywhere he hasn't
gone everywhere to learning he just
learned how to read a couple of seasons
ago thank you
okay well I'm not done because it gets
worse because she responds and says I
well I'm from the island of naath you
know like you wouldn't know what kind of
thing and he's like oh yeah I've heard
it's got the butterflies and those palm
trees all over the place and she does
that move instead of like yeah cool or
like oh no it's not great whatever the
way I am about Miami where I kind of
like put it down or whatever I I'm from
there don't love it
she doesn't do any of that instead she
goes hmm but you're thinking that he's
caught her out because she can't confirm
nor deny about the palm trees or the
butterfly didn't it seem a little bit
like he was potentially going like oh
yeah you know how on that island there's
all those palm trees ins up and her
reaction would tell him okay you know a
lot about this island or not and instead
she gives him no reaction I just thought
she was just being the female boss the
situation at her and Danny of doing
where it's like hey lesbian instant
beach men maybe it's totally could that
it also could totally be not armas on
day oh I did not think about it like
that it doesn't necessarily mean the
mossad days turned on us it just it
could also mean we didn't have that well
it happened when she was like hey grey
worm I'm finally ready for something or
who knows I know oh my gosh I study and
I'm not even going to say that it's
definitely Masson day because we do got
to look at I mean it was a little too
obvious to say it could be Varys but
this scene really reminded me that there
is supposed to be the master of whispers
yes and he ain't been doing that lately
right where they old have gone to so
many different locations Brett so his
his little bird they're supposed to be
feeding all this information why would
he not know what Cersei knows yeah why
would he not know this this these plans
that are involving the entirety of the
Lannister force being moved out of their
castle and moved elsewhere
no one leaked that there's gonna be
leaks but that's people in her camp and
totally again she could be sabotage from
within her camp but you have a theory
that it's actually not happening in
Danny's camp no I don't think there's a
mole necessarily there I think that 30s
just got a lot of whispers happening
herself let's see who's in her council
you've got Jamie and Jamie here
obviously is a big tactician he
understands employee of the land but
what does human
you have in common Casterly Rock and the
childhood that Tyrion kind of was
neglected from the whole life he was
always an outcast
so Tyrion said going I know exactly what
they're going to do but there's two
Lannister's in the thirsty camp and only
one in Danny's camp so I'm thinking the
twins have a little bit more power
together that's one of my ideas but
another one is Qyburn people heroes and
we finished unit player in this game
he's managed to stop death and in this
instance we've saw him and to last at
the end of last season he's got his own
little spiders spires and little birds
as well and I'm thinking maybe he's
pockets a little bit deeper and he's
paying you guys a better price because
maybe they've changed loyalties so no
longer beerus it's now Qyburn and why is
it got such a big deck to be on bank in
Braavos totally valid possibilities my
favorite of the ones you said is the one
where it's their twinspeak powers that
they have together like every twin has a
lot of power but up next we are done
with our big question we will get to
more questions in just a second but we
do it every episode we're going to do
our big famous map check-in I'm real
proud of this map because I built it and
it gets blurry if i zoom in too far but
I'm still proud of it but we're just
going to do a real quick rundown of
where people move to because there was a
lot of movement this time but basically
we are showing you which camp is moving
where and why all of a sudden and yeah
lots been happening yes you know if you
want to compare you can check out last
week's episode and you'll see where
these people came from but I'm just
going to jump to the ones that move so
we now know that inside of Winterfell we
have gained another start brain is
finally arrived or is it we will get to
who exactly arrived at Winterfell I'm
not talking about cute adorable Mira and
she was just kind of like do I get two
stops now oh yeah yeah and then moving
further south this is going to be a mess
so pay you got to pay some attention
here a lot of people moved around so
we're going to start where it's nice and
simple alright so we know that Danny is
the Targaryen force still at Dragonstone
we know that Tyrion is still with her we
now know that young mr. Jon Snow
has new she's gained him now I at
Dragonstone we're not going to unite
their circles because that's for them to
do when they both consent him like each
other we also we also know that Davos is
with him now I'm going to point out a
little bit of a weird kind of thing here
on the map that we don't fully know
right here we've got a Greyjoy sigil
because we don't know where Theon is
right now we know he's been picked up by
what sounds like the two ships that made
it out after the yer on destruction of
yar asleep
those ships don't necessarily have to go
back and rejoin Danny like they already
had I also will say I don't think
they'll go back to the iron Island and
rejoined you're on because he'll welcome
yeah give him next miles uh but right
now Theon and where he's headed at a
total mystery but he's with a Greyjoy
somewhere in the water in the Narrow Sea
uh to the far south I'll point out that
there is now adorn force that we don't
know who the hell's running it and
that's the question that we have no
clues about so but they'll find that I'm
saying that waiting to need to be picked
up what to do by the curb and they're
like waiting for the uber but he's not
showing up I'm not getting a five-star
rating and then things start to get
complicated as we move more toward the
West
this is a cluster Oh so first off I'm
going to note that there in King's
Landing we now have I think this might
be the last time we see this sigil
honestly is our Martel force actually
says he's going to make sure that Allari
is down there for quite some time yeah
I'm actually saying like let's go ahead
and retire her from the map because I
think she's not getting out of there
we'll bring her back if she comes back
but we had Elia Martell and tyene
Martell
unfortunately hanging out in a Cell
maybe next to what's her face of the
mountain was ruining yeah exactly
I'm trying to cook up the kiss of death
though right - she's fine our server and
then of course we have Cersei over in
King's Landing but further to the west
that this is where things start to get
interesting so I'm going to hop to the
Far West to remind us that the Targaryen
force had left in that previous episode
to go to Casterly Rock
that was part of the original plan they
did not stop it because of the fleet
being disrupted and they split in two so
this is the unsullied and this is grey
worm now who showed up on the outside
that you're on Greyjoy just for a second
so it took two episodes to the unsullied
to get from there all the way around and
it took your on what he ended up killing
most of the fleet and taking them out
and a cush man who's God is bringing the
the air in no sales we've got three
sales mod so it doesn't mean three times
the speed put on your urine apparently
does so we have your on there real quick
someone asked why didn't your on take
them down on their way there you got to
remember the brilliance of the plan of
waiting till they got out of the ship to
go inside a castle rock those were empty
ships that they were taking down a lot
easier to take those down and then this
is just our mess over here so secretly
Jamie had already known that they were
going there and taken all the Lannister
forces that were formula castle a rock
to Highgarden which is the seat of the
Tourelles the Tourelles being the most
wealthy in Westeros wealthy not really
great not great at fighting though
there's a little bit of a weird thing
there because they previously saved
King's Landing they arrived just in time
to Tyrell Army but you know I don't know
that they're not they're not nothing
fighters but the kind of are still
butter up against the way yeah yeah yeah
there was a lot of skipping some battles
here and the reason why they were such a
threat is that the Tarly force was there
with the Lannister force they just wiped
out the Tyrell family and force entirely
putting the head of the family so
unfortunately I think we might lose this
Tyrell surge on the map - and then we
got still our sand boy ID down in Old
Town and you didn't make me want to
throw up this week
that's something just direct it means
that there's no awful little editing
clips then of course because I know
we're not going to bring up spent oh
well Tata Lee Samwell Tarly never again
this episode because nothing's really
happening
what if he's a punishment of scribing
and copying Sea Scrolls that have got
the mites and mold what if he discovers
some
pivotal information in that I think
there will be in fact I know that Eric
is going to do an entire theory time
about it and the breakdown this week
watch that he has a very interesting
idea of where the entirety of the
samwell tarly storyline is going gosh
Philip that's a sweet sweet crust
emotion is happening it happened easily
and naturally another we called it out
it's ruined sorry cool so that's what
that is happening on the map you see the
movement we can beat all the forces of
basically I feel like I know where the
reporter gathering down in the south of
Westeros right now and that's about to
get really ugly but the point of our
show is a Q&A we love to hear from you
guys we obviously want to make sure that
the conversation is happening from
Twitter to the show and to do that all
you have to do is use that hashtag
Westeros weekly and you can talk about
any conspiracies you can talk about any
questions that you may have maybe
something didn't really make sense and
you want to get a better understanding
of it or maybe you've got something
spot-on and we can be like you're really
awesome
there are things that can happen by the
way sorry some of you don't use the
hashtag but you do ask the question
please use a hashtag because the people
that collect the question search by the
hashtag so you've got to write that
hashtag Westeros weekly I'm so sorry you
just got to yeah one rule so but
speaking of a question here's your first
one and this one is related to myth
Daenerys Targaryen herself it's at
Andrew three three six three seven says
now that they brought it up who is the
first to try and ride a dragon I think
it's really interesting that he says now
that they brought it up what he's
referring to is in the war room they
were saying that Danny could just go
destroy a fleet with her self and drogon
and her just on the back and they're
like well that doesn't make a ton of
sense when you can be taken out by like
the smallest arrow water and that's what
makes sense but I understand her plan
now obviously nothing else is working
and these ships of neurons are obviously
supernatural you need to take them out
wooden ships three dragons it makes
perfect sense except for the fact that
she is really just too valuable so we've
talked about this before actually of
what would happen if Daenerys needed
other people to ride her dragon and a
lot of our breakdowns went into theories
about who the other Dragon Riders could
be and we specifically went a lot into
the
targaryen czar kind of dragon whisperers
and they can hop on there and they can
ride a lot of people have surmised well
as in john ATAR garyun so people are
thinking john would be an answer to this
question other people are thinking that
john is the Targaryen that we know about
and there's actually a third head to the
dragon that it could be Tyrion which is
a very interesting theory he there's a
lot of the Tywin pushing he's not
actually his son so there's reason to go
into that but those have been been there
done that answers of like well they'll
probably ride it I'm curious mod if you
have any ideas for other people that are
a little less on the nose of who will be
the Dragon Riders yeah I got a few
theories you know how they work great
worm is going to be a really great
advocate and while I'm advocating for
him because he's the leader of the
unsullied this guy's proved himself time
and time in battle so I think he Gris
worm honor on a dragon yes is he won yes
so know that you will not refer to a
dragon as a worm
there's a Dumbo's is the most divergent
animals that have ever existed it's like
you know they're like worms no I think
the right ones going to be great on
there as well we've seen how is great
with the spirit and so that would be
great and yak and he's brilliant he
could attack tactically brilliant he
could totally lead a force with the
dragon I just might be a bit weed but
she needs a bit more of a purpose now
Melisandre so she is a big precess of
The Lord of Light who is attune with
fire she's used to burning things I
think that she would get on the back of
the dragon and do some damage and love
every second of it I love that your
argument is essentially like you know
who's a pyro Melisandre and she's pretty
good her death already in Westeros how
possibly on the back of a dragon oh you
think it's like like into the flames
like we're going now like crashing the
plane into the people or telling the
purpose all along and of course girls
look great on dragons as we've
established in this series to the last
one of course who I think will never be
on the dragon but should be on a dragon
ghost Jon Snow's dire wolf I just
picture like yeah what was not sure is
that one of the Power Rangers where
they'll have the beast animals and they
all connected and made like a giant
beast that's what's going to happen is
o'clock is good
duct-tape dragon it's a power animal now
and it's like we can't breathe very nice
applies to people I love this actually
because I love the image in fact if if
you guys will Photoshop or draw or do
whatever you want of ghost writing a
dragon artwork right up this is because
yeah as the Ghost Rider Ghost riding a
dragon we will feature it at the end of
next week's episode if you so mad -
hashtag Westeros Weekly be cool thank
you for indulging me alright time for
our next question this one comes in from
Zach back in nine eight seven six five
four three two my question he says why
didn't Jon wanna tell Daenerys about
dying and his resurrection great
question I was thinking about it as well
obviously we noticed in the show you had
a boss there he was stepping up he was
announcing John eventually you're
stepping up any message on snooze yeah
King the daughter who's 17 - today but
what you love about devil is aqip the
friend you want he can talk up brilliant
people the hope man he's the best fight
man yeah outfit but he's about to say
this man has literally taken you know
nice to the heart and Jon's like dude -
dude don't bring out the whole
resurrection - and of course we have to
ask why Phillip you apparently have an
answer yeah I think there's there's two
reasons here why Jon kind of does that
whole like ixnay on on the I'm kind of
this world's Jesus may yeah one like
coming on too strong about religion can
freak people out we saw it with mouth
Andra previously but that's not my full
reason I think John has just
specifically labeled their enemy as the
walking dead men yeah non Walking Dead
different show but the walking dead men
are your enemies he just said that
essentially so for him to within seconds
of having said that be identified as a
walking dead person it's just a whole
other thing that he would have to come
to clarify but it's not that I think
she'd be confused it really brings me to
reason number two as to why I think he
needs all this back he just said
the craziest stuff Daenerys was like she
looked at Taran she's like yo your boys
like broken right and like turns like no
no no I vouch for him you know he's he's
he's fine I know he's talking about like
monsters beyond the wall but it's all
the way over there it's like a second
later John is like also I'm one of the
dead monsters that came back to life -
she would just have that moment of like
oh I get it
you're crazy you're all crazy you have a
cult in the north it's all weird and
full of crazy people got it I know one
person that could really bounce for him
in a way that not only gives evidence
but puts her in the same picture here's
Melisandre and she's long gone she was
the one who brother John she's the one
who's also seen the effects of the north
and the monsters behind the wall - but
yeah that's super convenient right it's
kind of like a deep move though - it's
like don't bring up all your awkward
baggage so you have it scares people off
but coming up next we have another
question also related to the people here
at Dragonstone but it's actually about
my man at Davos and that moment that we
hinted at earlier yeah at Mike ez7 it
says he's calling out this moment where
Dan is getting her introduction he says
if Jon Snow was introduced like Danny
what would his whole title have been in
his in your opinion and so yeah we have
Danny getting this hilarious
introduction it's so long Masada is like
hey alakina yeah I think they're adding
stuff on Days just like messing around
now she's like you know sitter of chair
which is the most awkward chair to sit
in by the way it looks like she's
crouching her and stuff like actually
sitting yeah but she just keeps going in
John and Davos just keep watching so
this guy basically just wants to know if
Davos got another chance other than just
this is Jon Snow he's king of north what
would you have him say all right I had a
big think about this one and I think the
devil should I get a big think about it
he's got quite a lot as well but there's
a few key mentioned in this episode as
well which I think we should add to it
because every every title that Daenerys
aside is basically breaking down where
she's on every season yeah
that is a recap every episode so and as
we like your highness this is John's new
bastards dark by birth for know we'll
get to more of that later father of
direwolf not plural just the one layer
of whites and walkers but you don't
believe that teller of truth but you
don't believe him still beautiful
brooder as tyrion has just seen and
riser of death which I'm not allowed to
talk about but he's also the king of the
north and that's what's important
thank you very much that was like nine
really bad accents combined yeah it was
people are going nuts in there and
they're all like wondering why he does
commentary on his own titles as he goes
it's like you know I shouldn't have said
this one comma but me but I just wanna
keep up I was gonna call it the Battle
of the bastard I do yeah trace that's a
fair game now all right that question
has been answered by moving on we've got
one from at no underwear underscore
woman why is brand and motionless when
dealing with Sansa could he know that
she will soon die that's a whole lot of
heavy obviously we know the reunion in
Winterfell more than a glorious it was
as we'd hoped this the first time
indices range while yeah man he lost all
social etiquette or just out of be
basically said hugged robot it should
empty inside was just like oh she is
touching me thank you
human like it seems some stuff and when
I say stuff I mean iron or millennia of
things that have happened in the town
sorry in all of Westeros and Essos in a
sense that are you giving the hug they
won't have a little bit of how well a
little bit of chat hanging out you've
been right in a while let's head out to
the godswood do notice though that there
was no blood coming out of there
so should I thought is it good sign
except bran being a widow not a good
sign
so people are calling with that quite
perfectly basically fans the ones the
insight and information is like hey
maybe explain to me what this whole
three-eyed Raven is that I've never
heard of and that you apparently are and
then Brandy's kids it looks really
beautiful the night that you marry do a
rapist in all this brilliance the worst
moment of your life really pretty and so
she's like whoa and he's like well and
it's like cool so what is that with bran
you know why does he
bring that up he's so insane in that
moment and you did this world coming to
the wall first of all he's like how do
we know you're a sock and he's like I'm
going to pinpoint a no-fun event that I
wasn't at me like cool we don't know
when your uncle's okay here you're you
come through the wall so many different
know that that sounds like hey man that
was a killer jump that you did off the
wall there we were beyond but know how
pretty was your wedding dress when you
married the worst person on the kind of
hit her like her key point in recent
history I think that's why you went to
it it was still extremely awkward let
alone it's her little brother's the
worst night of her life but I think the
answer to this question is really that
he's got this this wealth of information
in his head I really think that you know
he's not brand anymore he sees the
computer who wore tennis shoes he's a
the the three-eyed Raven and
unfortunately he doesn't really care
about did those emotional attachments
that normal people have he just knows he
needs to play a part in the destiny of
these lands but here's what's really
interesting to me the idea that he's so
rough and short with Sansa right there
because since he knows everything
maybe he knows she's not part of what's
to come
John is he's very clearly like it's
super excited to get to John which would
makes him wonder if like he does--he
John he's not robotic at all he's just
like Oh John man Sansa hello your rapist
was I was like God but John he has all
this energy towards because he knows
that John is playing a huge role
so it's Sansa either not really gonna
play a huge role or she's potentially
gonna die that is not a good sign that
he doesn't care so much about talking to
her I want to see Sansa use the flip
side of this and realize that having
bran of SIA
someone that can predict things look
back in the past and had so much
information this is now a weapon that
she comes and because she's on
leadership 101 I think that she needs to
realize once you figure out what bran is
you can write anyway it's like how they
use madam Cleo on the Gulf War I mean
just it makes sense my real question for
you guys though is so brand mission is
straight-up I got to get to John I got
to tell him the truth about something
we're gonna
soon right now but we don't actually
know that this is about his heritage how
is that gonna affect the war why does
brand think that is so ultimately
important the destiny of lance for John
to know that he is not who he thinks he
is so that's one question for you guys
let us know in the comments
alrighty question number five we've got
is from at ma ma ma I've got mama 9 the
musical one thank you so she has no
intention of pain her death the urine or
the iron bank does she
hashtag Westeros weekly oh she's product
kinda hit the nail on the head here so
he obviously realizes to win war you
need the cash and she hasn't been in the
good books with the iron back for some
time they've been knocking on her door
going pay up pay up and she's like haha
hold that thought in this particular
instance though she's stuck with all
this debt but she's in a very good
position strategically which we didn't
know about it in this particular part of
the episode hence they give me two weeks
and I'll get you bro we've got Tyco and
historic he went and got Tyco with your
money money money money
the week and by the way this was Mycroft
home which you can't unsee those as
those Sherlock's didn't show up like
solves this whole thing I didn't also
though I mean that's not the only person
that she owes you're on also has been
like very much like remember how you
agreed to marry me and sleep with me if
I do if she's like no I did say I need
that but I am I am kind of into you
though yeah so I guess the real question
this person has though is she going to
get that money back to the iron bank and
also big is she gonna get with your on
because she did say you know I'll make
your dreams come true or whatever and
they in a couple weeks I think yes and
yet so we know the first one she's or
she's already got a bunch of gold from
raiding my garden so that's the money
thing sorted out my thing is though
she's managed to convince Tyco not to
bother with Daenerys because that's not
a sure bet and she needs a sure bet I
think that was very well done similar to
Stannis making that same kind of case
that's it cutting odds and yourself
financially huge because it's a lot of
Dothraki mouths to feed but the whole
hey now that I've got this money I'm
going to borrow a whole stack more money
because I am a sure bet
what I'm thinking is that she'll be like
absolutely I'll pay you back once the
war is done she's the kind of psycho
that will make sure the war is never
done so that they the Lannister will pay
the debt that is a promise and so you
know change the rules basically well
then I think that's a lot of motor oil
is always positive they pride themselves
on pun so I think that she will stand by
that but she's going to to keep pushing
back that end date right the thing with
your on though this I think is going to
be the breaking point for Jaime because
of oh my gosh she's hearing it from
everyone he's hearing it from Elena he's
hearing it from Euron all the stuff with
a Sophie's a psycho be I'm going to do
some naughty things to her how does she
like it right we and it's getting bad
Jamie's breaking point
so Euron will get thirsty and that will
lose Jamie and some predictions
there you go speaking of actually I will
hit the up in predictions I agree with
the concept of everything you're saying
I just don't literally think it's going
to happen that way but we'll get to that
in predictions pretty soon that's it for
our main questions of this week the real
exciting part though the thing that you
guys voted on is our Power Rankings I'm
really excited to get to them this week
because I'm really happy about the
results of people to get to the Power
Rankings all I have to do is follow on
Twitter and there's a good new rock
stars will post every single week after
the episode a new link to the poll we
release it right after the episode airs
and you guys can vote literally any
character that appeared in the episode
is eligible for the power to win the
Power Rankings that week and I think
that came into play this week and I'm
really excited about it time so we
should just get right to them yeah
obviously that parenting is the
political influence that these
characters have and how much they've
changed the progression of where
everything is going coming at number
three 6.7% Euron Greyjoy this is huge
loss he won lastly yeah he was the top
person last week and yeah I know you
might be thinking well he's still in the
top three of all the people but look at
that number 6.7%
it was real close between the fourth and
the fifth I mean a lot of people are
around the five and six percent area
yeah interesting I mean he's won the
hearts of King's Landing but he hasn't
won the power
rankings this week at number two Olenna
Tyrell at 7.5% yeah what a palpable man
an unbaked way as well I love that that
she showed up and is reppin here in the
power ranking out of all places we're
going to talk more about her in a second
but we still do that acknowledge like
who's this is Abbas made this week now
dying words is going to change the
future of this show coming a number one
though now this is frightening 61.5%
that is I think more than double pretty
much every previous first place position
we have had and that everybody agrees is
Cersei Lannister she is two steps ahead
here I love how it was like tired
Kyrian's going well I've got a little
backdoor and Chris at Seder know about
and we're going to win is oh my god we
are so screwed right yeah this was
Circe's best week in the series best
week of her life maybe I mean you can
see that she gets off on what she did
this week and she's like none I like I
don't venture in myself she gets a high
to Highgarden
she get yer on favor and the gift she
gets everything she gets Jamie
unwillingly kind of is like no means no
a little bit there but she's just like
no I'm in charge this is how we do it I
didn't really hear him saying no he was
he was like you know eventually it's a
lie I was it's fun
but at first he's like no we shouldn't
we shouldn't we shouldn't I mean this
was nice that's a very interesting thing
obviously Jamie's arc is not done at all
yet things are going to change I'm going
to planted that seed so Josie's doubtful
I think could be not everything around
her but it's the one she didn't see
coming
can we talk a little bit more about a
lemma though real quick yes the best
part of the show and I think it's very
interesting to say for 20 years if
you're a book reader and four sixties as
we wanted to see John and Danny come
together and it wasn't the most exciting
part of this episode when it did happen
the fact that she went out the way she
did describing the way she murdered
Jamie's son is
is absolutely satisfying but it's also
the final insult because of that part
works like I just want Cersei to know
that Cersei may have won the power
rankings this week but between episodes
there's a nice little Raven or something
or when Jaime gets back there she gets
the last blow in and that's such a cool
way to go just know of course you chug
you're saying it's like alright well
thanks you idiot you let me die very
sweetly and nice lately why didn't she
mention paid a little fingers
participation in any of that I think
honestly the best reason to say that she
didn't is because it makes her look like
that much more of that it's like I'm the
one that did it like to say like me and
Littlefinger did it doesn't quite land
that same blow also it's not up to her
to sell out someone that she had an
alliance with the some point in her
going moment it's like you know what I'm
going to out all my stuff and my
consciousness clean and he can do what
he wants real quick we should before we
jump out of here remember that just like
alehna taught us the way to have power
isn't always a traditional way and every
other week the person who led the
killcount was also the person who was on
top of the Power Rankings except this
week it's mr. gray were that's right
we were damaged a couple did he had one
imaginary set of damage that didn't
actually happen with the ladders and
then he had actual damage that had that
he landed but we are account is around
10 direct kills from gray where we set
now yeah again real quick the way we
count these is on screen kills that
literally one person killing another
person gray room wins that count but it
kind of shows that just because he was
able to do that doesn't mean that's
power he still neutered as a force
terrible but really good yeah but but he
is right it's like they have the castle
and they can't do anything with it and
we won and we have a no they haven't won
the wall yeah that didn't even argue
they won the battle at that point you
know what I mean like this whole day out
from under it yes thank you stickers
just one big participation trophy in the
middle of Castle Rock and they have that
good on you but yeah but we don't know
if you won't and that's one thing that
we might examine next episode so let's
go ahead and give the teaser for next
week a watch animal me on the other side
with our predictions I only venture at
this moment to be establishing control
over this continent and every person on
it
my allies are gone I'm losing you can
count on the iron bank as soon as the
gold arrived
enough with the clever plan
wowie Danny looks different I'm I'm
excited about what I think I saw going
on in there
there was a man they need to cut so damn
quick but what is your big prediction
for next week based on what we just saw
that Danny is super super desperate now
and John just happens to be there with a
really good arrangement non-thinking the
more they get to know each other can I
see you about to go won't was right that
chemistry there was amazing oh my
favorite kind stubborn two sovereign
energies of commoditized lucky
developers if you know I don't talk me
about but that's what's going to happen
here they get a Butthead and the egos
gonna be so in the way and they realize
they're fighting for the same thing gift
gift gift so maybe they have some fun oh
he is going into a cave next week and we
know he likes to do it in case that's
true and one last thing I want to make a
point of is this is the second time
we've been in a preview your cap or
dagger [ __ ] that comes into my
somehow whether it's I are using it
because she is fond of daggers and
needles you know I noticed something
about that shot that I'm not going to
talk about because you could consider it
a spoiler I'll just say you can
recognize the Rings holding the dagger
mmm click so if I can watch that yeah my
prediction for next week is based on a
moment that you see in there that has a
lot to do with the gold we know
everything solved in two weeks when the
gold gets here I think the gold ain't
coming I think the gold is not going to
make it back to King's Landing because
you know what we've had a lot of Cersei
having her way I have a feeling that
that same March that they're talking
about being very difficult to make cross
Westeros some version of that is going
to happen with this gold and it's going
to get just chopped off in the middle
because that puts Cersei and I backed in
a corner position again and that's where
I love her and that's why doing the
showrunners love her so that's my
prediction for next week the Cersei
money paying off her debt plan is not
going to work and just gonna get real I
love it you're right I should spend too
much favor not too many episodes I want
to see them come up and not the word I
thought behind we need it no you should
use it more often
I'm always teaching a different one
every single yeah that's a nice thank
you so much for joining us by the way
from subscribe to the channel now is the
time to do it meet a million what uh
yeah anything I would have been rude on
my hand for eating [ __ ] the other day I
for in the last thirty seconds of this
show I my name is Margaret if you do
watch I got more of me just make sure
you hit up geek balm on YouTube as well
give that one a subscribe to lots of
content coming out well know you've got
one thing I've got a name - its bill
Molina I have my soda annals at fimo P
you want to hit me up with any direct
question but again save those questions
most of them about the episode for the
hashtag Westeros weekly you'll do it
next week but until then really excited
to see what you guys come up with with
the ghost dragon artwork please don't
send that in and we'll see at the end of
next week's episode thank you so much
bye bye
you